so what I wanted to do here is go over
all the forms of the Super Saiyan -
Dragon Ball GT
and what I'm hoping is that this video
serves as both an informational video
for new fans as well as a nostalgia trip
for older fans what I also want to throw
out here is that this video was made
with the help of geekdom 101 and so if
you're interested click the annotation
on the screen to head over to his
channel and check them out
the false Super Saiyan so the false
Super Saiyan form actually appears in
Dragon Ball Z movie number four which
involved a villain named Lord slug and
the original Japanese film Lord slug was
one of a few extremely powerful
namekians referred to as super nameks
and was also a would-be conqueror of
worlds after arriving on earth with the
intention of terraforming the planet
Lord slug learns of the existence of the
Dragon Balls which he uses to regain his
youth following the implementation of a
global terraforming device a battle
rages between Goku and Lord slug with
the other Z warriors out of commission
due to Lord slugs henchmen and with no
one able to offer Goku their power
Goku suddenly takes on a powerful form
with a yellow aura but maintains his
dark hair now the accepted definition of
this false Super Saiyan form is that
it's the result of a sand that has the
power to become a Super Saiyan but lacks
the ability to control that power
instead they fight mindlessly at a state
of complete rage as was seen in Goku's
battle with Ward slug it's something I'd
also like to draw your attention to is
that in his video about the various
super saiyan stages geekdom 101 had
mentioned that this transformation was
initially meant to be the first Super
Saiyan transformation but because of
Keira Toriyama hadn't informed the
animation studio that the Super Saiyan
was supposed to have blonde hair and
green eyes following Goku's
transformation against Frieza the name
of false Super Saiyan was adopted in
order to explain this stage of power
Super Saiyan level 1 so the first actual
Super Saiyan transformation came during
Goku's fight with Frieza and Dragon Ball
Z episode number 66 titled Goku's new
power during his explanation Vegeta had
stated that according to the legend the
last Super Saiyan appeared 1,000 years
before the events of Namek and could
only maintain their power in a transform
state what I'd also like to draw your
attention to is the golden ape
appearance of this version of the Super
Saiyan because it will become a key
point of our discussion with the Super
Saiyan God however the power possessed
by the being in Vegeta's tale of the
legendary Super Saiyan was so extreme
that they were unable to control it and
ended up being destroyed by their own
power
however while Vegeta himself admitted
that he never believed in the legend the
story was found to be true in episode
number 95 of the English dub titled
transformed at last the following the
death of Krillin at the hands of Frieza
Goku's rage over the loss of his friend
allowed him to ascend to the power of a
super saiyan in the dragon balan cycle
edia release in 1993 title dies in 2:7
what we're told is that while the
physical form of a Super Saiyan only
provides a bit of increased muscle mass
as well as yellow hair and green eyes
the true benefit of a Super Saiyan comes
in the power boost which is largely
accepted to be 50 times that of the
user's maximum power prior to their
transformation
Super Saiyan grades so following Super
Saiyan level 1 come a series of interim
grades between Super Saiyan level 1 and
Super Saiyan level 2 Super Saiyan grade
2 or send it Saiyan as this more
commonly referred to was achieved by
Vegeta following his training in the
room of spirit and time during the
Android saga and provides an increase in
both speed and power the Super Saiyan
grade 3 or ultra Super Saiyan as is
referred to by fans was demonstrated by
trunks during his time battling cell
following his absorption of Android 18
allowing him to enter his perfect form
while in this stage strength and speed
are increased beyond the levels of Super
Saiyan grade 2 but because this form is
so bulky the speed benefit is completely
negated resulting in its user possessing
incredible strength and power but not
enough speed for any of it to matter the
final stage of Super Saiyan level 1 is
referred to as Super Saiyan grade 4 or
full power Super Saiyan achieved by Goku
and Gohan during their training in the
room of spirit and time where the
initial transformation into a Super
Saiyan and subsequent grades are
accessed and maintained through need
desire or sometimes pure rage the full
power Super Saiyan is a demonstration of
complete mastery of the Super Saiyan
form allowing us wielder to access their
power without losing any self-control
Super Saiyan 2 so the term Super Saiyan
2 is both a misnomer and an accurate
term at the same time what I mean here
is that originally Super Saiyan level 2
was referred to as Super Saiyan grade 5
with the term Super Saiyan 2 unused
until Goku's battle with boo and his
tour of the various super saiyan stages
the first access by Gohan during his
training in the room of spirit and time
his initial transformation was temporary
and that like the Super Saiyan
transformation and emotional upheaval is
necessary to achieve this state because
Gohan seemed to be tapping into his
latent powers but was unable to hold on
to it the power dissipated almost
immediately however during the Cell
games following Android 16 speech on the
value of life and his destruction at the
hands of self Gohan had the emotional
experience necessary to allow him to
fully accesses Super Saiyan level to
form after attaining this form the power
strength and stamina achieved by a Super
Saiyan is doubled but at the cost of the
inner piece gained in their mastery over
the Super Saiyan form reverting back to
being governed by their emotions an
individual in this stage actually has to
war to match this form in order to
regain their inner peace Super Saiyan 3
first demonstrated by Goku during his
battle with Majin Buu in the English dub
titled Super Saiyan 3 this form is a
massive drain on energy while Goku was
in this form during his one day back on
earth
the energy expended actually took away
from the amount of time that he had left
furthermore once he was given new life
due to the sacrifice of the old chi the
energy expenditure of the Super Saiyan 3
form was demonstrated during his fight
with Majin Buu in its true form during
the battle on the planet of Kai's Goku's
energy was expended faster than he could
use it resulting in him reverting back
to his normal form in the middle of the
fight with the inability to regain his
energy however the question that remains
unanswered among fans is whether or not
this stage can be mastered in the same
capacity as a Super Saiyan level one
form because Super Saiyan level 3 only
appeared at the end of the Dragon Ball Z
series and was only used for a few
minutes in Dragon Ball super an
explanation currently does not exist on
whether or not this form can be mastered
Broly
so brawling is a bit of a quagmire and
is actually a source of contention among
fans in truth
Broly was introduced for two reasons the
first was to provide a character whose
ability to become super saiyan was
genetic with a form belonging solely to
themselves and the other was to
reconcile the legend of the super saiyan
with the fact that Super Saiyans now
existed following Goku's transformation
during the frieza saga brawly's
legendary Super Saiyan form is akin to
the ultra Super Saiyan form but in truth
no Speed is lost
instead broglie's form seems to
transcend not just the normal Super
Saiyan form but even the Super Saiyan
level to form in that during his
original appearance his strength speed
endurance and stamina were all increased
well beyond that of Earth's heroes and
he was able to single-handedly take out
all of the Z warriors including Goku
Vegeta piccolo and Trunks with Goku
having to combine everyone's energy to
actually harm Brawley in addition to
this when he returned in movie number 10
Super Saiyan 2 gohan was only able to
stun brawl it with his
the something that I think is worth
mentioning here though is that as a
teenager
Gohan strength was far less than it was
when he battled cell as a child Super
Saiyan God so with the Super Saiyan God
weakened into some murky waters here and
in truth the legend of the Super Saiyan
seems to be read conned with this reveal
and the movie battle of the gods
according to Shenron the Super Saiyan
God is not something that could be
reached with training instead the form
is attained when five pure-blooded
sayings combine their energies into a
six pure blooded Saiyan according to the
legend at some point in Planet Vegeta's
history a civil war took place between
the Saiyan race pitting evil Saiyans
against good Saiyans combining their
energy a small group of good Saiyans
were able to produce the Super Saiyan
God who in turn vanquished evil in his
form while Goku was able to hold his own
against beerus in terms of speed and
reaction time the damage he inflicted
was minimal furthermore according to
Goku the drawback to this form is that
it's not something that he can attain on
his own Super Saiyan God Super Saiyan so
the Super Saiyan God Super Saiyan as it
was seen and resurrection of F is the
version expected to appear in the Dragon
Ball super TV show with a Super Saiyan
God form seen in battle of the gods
required the power of six pure Saiyans
this form as it's seen in resurrection
of F appears to be a level attainable by
Saiyans but furthermore because Dragon
Ball super took the Battle of the Gods
plot reworked it and expanded it the
idea of a Super Saiyan God seems to be a
Rubidoux sorts in that like the original
Super Saiyan form the Super Saiyan God
Super Saiyan form may have its own
varying grades and levels however at
this point not enough information has
been given for us to know with that
being said we're going to bring this
video to an end and let me know who your
favorite Super Saiyans are in the world
of Dragon Ball for that being said I
will catch you guys later peace